all right guys
bang bang i have a very special guest
today
lee is here thank you so much for uh for
doing this
yeah thank you so much anthony for
having me on the show
i don't know if i'm supposed to call you
that tom
you're good uh let's start with your
background um kind of explain to
everyone what you did
uh before you started atelier yeah
for sure so um before starting atelier
this summer
i was an investing partner at andreessen
horowitz which is a venture capital firm
in the bay area
and i was on the consumer investing team
there for the past four years
where i focused on marketplaces consumer
software
social networks professional networks
anything with a network effect really
was
very much in our sweet spot of what we
were interested in
and yeah how far back should i go i'm
originally from beijing
um chinese was my first language i moved
to
the states when i was six years old um
and grew up in pittsburgh and that's
what led me to
being where i am today speaking english
that's awesome i love that
um let's go into this passion economy so
you coined this term
uh you've done a ton of work you are
probably the leading expert on what the
passion economy
is so give us kind of a quick summary as
to what is the passion economy and kind
of how did you discover this
yeah so i i describe it as the passion
economy is
the economy in which people are able to
convert what they love to do
into their source of income and
i think that in general it's a intrinsic
human desire
to find meaning and purpose in one's
work not just
to earn money from it i think for most
people for much of
human history um people have always
wanted
to love what they do to enjoy their time
spent
earning a living and to be able to see
themselves in their own work
but i think that it was very
traditionally before the internet it was
really difficult for people to
be able to work in that way you needed
to um
sort of be employed at a company do a
very specialized role and now
i think a wave of new platforms are
arising that
democratize the ability to create a
product or service
find customers do all the back office
work required to manage
a company and earn income and so it's
easier than ever
before for people to actually leverage
their unique skills
and knowledge um to be able to earn an
income
and uh how i became interested in this
and
and where it came from i think so for me
it really stemmed from
that time at a16z where i was evaluating
marketplace businesses for the past four
years and
during that time from 2016 to 2020
i really saw this paradigm shift in
marketplace businesses that were coming
in to pitch me their startups uh when i
first joined the firm in 2016
i think it was still the era of the uber
for x startup
people were coming in pitching their
on-demand companies um
whether it was like on-demand car washes
or on-demand pet care or whatever
and the critical piece of having
an on-demand marketplace is that um
you have to really provide a ton of
convenience and simplicity and make sure
that as soon as a customer wants
something you can deliver it to them
and so the resulting way that you would
design a marketplace to be on demand is
that you have to
in a way commoditize all of the supply
side such that you can
just match the customer to whatever is
available at the time
like you can't give them so many options
that
it's unable you can't have liquidity
that way in a marketplace
and so a critical component of these
on-demand uber for x
marketplaces was that they commoditized
the supplier um driver a
is basically equivalent to driver b is
equivalent to driver c
um and this shows up in the design of
these marketplaces where
as a consumer when you request something
when you request a car
you don't even know the provider that
you're going to be matched with because
they've all
been commoditized to these various
service levels
and i think that on the supply side what
this meant was
even though you had this very turn-key
convenient way to make 10
20 it felt like you were sort of at the
mercy of the platform and the platform
was dictating
exactly what you needed to do in order
to make this money
and you weren't developing any customer
loyalty you weren't really
expressing any creativity or imagination
in the work that you were doing
and over the years i started seeing new
marketplaces
arise that i met with that
were offering not only an interesting
value proposition to consumers but they
were also
emphasizing the unique value proposition
that they gave to the supply
side too where they were creating a
marketplace that actually enabled
suppliers and workers to
leverage their creativity their
education their unique knowledge
in order to make a living and so the
marketplace or the platforms they were
really just a set of tools that these
workers could use to build their own
offering rather than accepting
directions from the platforms
and so i thought that this trend was
really interesting um
and i i basically synthesized all these
ideas in
the blog post that i published last year
called the passion economy and the
future of work
um and yeah i think it's
it's now much broader than just
marketplaces i'm
interested in all of the software
infrastructure that enables people to
take what they
enjoy doing and turn it into income like
that could be a marketplace where you're
matching people directly
it could also be a sas tool that people
are leveraging to build their own online
business it could be a creator tool that
helps people
make something more easily for an
audience
i'm also interested in like fintech and
education because i think those are
foundational components of things that
need to be in place for people to be
able to
discover what they're passionate about
and be able to manage their income
so like that is the whole scope of
all of my interests when it comes to
investing in the passion economy
got it and so when you say passion
economy i think a lot of people think of
oh this is the creators this is the
celebrities the youtubers and kind of
people that really create content right
and almost like the passion economy is
the content economy
maybe talk a little bit about the
nuances around what does the passion
economy
entail or encapsulate versus maybe what
it doesn't
yeah um so that is a very common
reaction that i get from people when i
talk about this
i get a lot of people asking me like
isn't this just the creator economy
and and they just assume that all the
workers that i'm talking about are
content creators
which i push back against because i
think the passion economy is much
broader than the creator economy
uh the creator economy is definitely a
sub-segment of it
but i think of the passion economy as
this bigger umbrella
and encompassing really anyone who
is passionate about their work and feels
very much
fulfilled and gets a sense of meaning
from their work
i think people glom on to creators
because it's this
like new type of profession that has
newly emerged in the last decade and
it's
you know quickly growing and underserved
but i think the passion economy is much
bigger than that and
and goes beyond people who are just
creating content per se
so for instance examples that i commonly
point to are
this is a portfolio company of mine
called dumpling
which helps people to build and manage
their own
local services business in the grocery
shopping and grocery delivery vertical
so in a way it's like a competitor to
instacart and
they're giving people the tools to start
manage and grow their own grocery
delivery business
and i consider that to be a part of the
passion economy even though these
shoppers would never in a million years
call themselves
a creator like they would never identify
with that term
and yet they are people who really enjoy
what they do for a living
on the customer side they view each
shopper as a distinct individual who
um develops loyalty with them they
they're skilled workers like they don't
view every grocery shopper as
completely interchangeable with each
other they actually want to work with
a certain individual time and time again
um
and on the worker side they actually
have real ownership and upside
in their work and they are small
business owners
um so that's an example of where i think
this
this would be part of the passion
economy in my view
but they're not a content creator and i
think there's there's so many other
professions out there
where the worker would never call
themselves a creator
um but they are part of this emerging
economy of people who are able to
leverage their unique skills
and turn that into their income and what
they do for a living
but they're not creating content per se
they're maybe providing a service
or teaching a curriculum that has
already been written
for them um or maybe they're doing sales
um but they're they're cultivating
loyalty but they're not creating content
yeah what's so interesting is like
before you coined that term the passion
economy i used to
tell people like it's entrepreneurship
right it's like
building something from scratch and
trying to figure out how do you make
money doing it right and
um one of the frameworks that i've heard
people use before is
that this is just the modern small
business right kind of it used to be
that
uh you went to school and then when you
wanted to start a business you had to go
get a physical
location on main street in some town and
you could start everything from a coffee
shop
to a woodworking shop or whatever it was
the internet obviously kind of empowered
more software and things like that
and we started to almost uh you know
really use the word
entrepreneurship or startups to describe
software high growth venture
backable type businesses i think really
what you're highlighting here
is like there's a new type of
entrepreneurship but it's actually just
the same thing in a new format right
it's the small businesses that used to
be on main street are now being created
via all of these tools and marketplaces
that you're trying to invest in is that
generally accurate you think yeah i
think that's a very apt description of
it
um i wrote a post on my newsletter
earlier this summer called unbundling
work from employment and it specifically
deals with that theme
of um yeah i think the fashion economy
is
really about people who are able to go
independent
and craft their own business and they no
longer need to be employed
at a company in order to access
customers
create a product or service um run their
business
etc like the the new smb is just a
single individual
who is leveraging all these software
platforms
and technology tools in order to run
their own business
and the common ground that they share
with the entrepreneurs
in back in the day is that they have
um this autonomy and ownership and they
feel very motivated in what they do
but i think the the unit of an smb has
shrunk to potentially a single
individual
yeah and talk a little bit about the
importance of the platforms in doing
that right because it feels like what
you're saying
is these individuals used to want to do
the work and they'd have to go to an
uh an organization or a company that
organization or a company provided all
the infrastructure that empowered them
to do the work
now though there's these tools and
platforms that are allowing them to do
it on their own
without the need for an organization
yeah
exactly um that's right so i think
different tools and platforms are
emerging
that make this kind of work accessible
to people
and they encompass both vertical
platforms where they're helping people
to create a certain
product or service that's aligned to a
specific vertical for instance a
newsletter
or a video course or an audio course or
a podcast
and then there's horizontal platforms
that people across different verticals
can leverage
so these are things like financial tools
for all independent workers
or community software platforms that can
serve all sorts of different
entrepreneurs and cultivating a
community
i i have this sort of image in my mind
of
the company that people used to be
employed at it was actually a bundle
of different services that they offered
to you um so a company
and being employed at a certain employer
it used to mean you got a bundle of
various things you got a bundle of like
the production aspect where the company
gave you the means of production
for something um there was the marketing
aspect
there was the income aspect all of like
the back office and administrative stuff
there was also team and camaraderie
provided
as being part of a company you got
access to all of your co-workers and you
had a sense of
being part of a team there's also like
learning and development
that the company used to provide and i
think in this new world
in the passion economy world um
new platforms are arising that take each
of those
component parts and have a software
um platform to replace that and to
provide the service that a company used
to bundle
all together so for instance that team
piece
there's lots of new social networks and
communities that
offer a team to
people who are basically micro
entrepreneurs i'm
in this telegram group with your wife
paulina
and we are all newsletter writers we all
write a sub stack or a mailchimp
newsletter some of us do it full time
some of us just do it as a hobby but
this is a source of camaraderie
um where we all relate to each other on
this common basis and i think
it's going to be more common for new
communities to emerge for these
solopreneurs that still want a sense of
camaraderie and teamwork but they aren't
employed at a common employer
got it and talk a little bit about how
monetization has changed right so
obviously when you work at an
organization uh you have a salary
you get paid kind of don't have to think
about it to some degree right you just
work
focus on the work obviously when you
kind of go on your own
and pursue a more entrepreneurial path
uh monetization is really important
right because you kind of
it's on you now and so how has that
monetization methods changed and also
like what do you see
working for people who are entering the
passion economy
yeah um i often refer
to this piece that kevin kelly wrote a
decade ago which i think is really
prescient
i never know how to pronounce that word
is it prussian to represent
um but he wrote this post called a
thousand true fans
um which i commonly refer to and he says
that
to be a successful creator on the
internet by creator he meant like anyone
who
was trying to make a living by creating
something
um you don't need to be a mega celebrity
with million followers you can just
you can just cultivate a loyal base of a
thousand followers
who are going to support you to the tune
of ten dollars
i think it was like yeah ten dollars per
month and
thereby earn about a hundred thousand
dollars per year
um i think the
the key underpinning insight of that
piece
is that the internet enables a direct
connection with the customer
you no longer need an intermediary who
is helping you with distribution and
marketing and helping you
create a product you can actually just
create something yourself
to cultivate loyalty and cultivate an
audience
of customers who are willing to support
you directly
and thereby keep the entire portion
of earnings that the the customer is
willing to pay you
and actually um the implication that
that has is that you need
far fewer customers in total than you
would have
in the old world where there was an
intermediary
so i think um in terms of monetization
mechanisms that are working
i think everything everything that
people used to make a living from before
they still apply today but i think the
novel way that a lot of how the long
tail
of online entrepreneurs are monetizing
is through that direct customer support
got it and in terms of um the
monetization methods i think there's a
big focus on subscription
and kind of fans paying but it also
feels like maybe there's been over
rotation there like yeah advertising is
still
a viable model and so do you see kind of
the hybrid working where people are kind
of pursuing multiple monetization
strategies
or do you feel like now we're really
seeing people kind of focus on one or
the other
yeah i i don't think that subscriptions
will work for everyone yeah i i think
that
we have put a ton of emphasis on
subscriptions and the media is
constantly talking about how people
are cultivating a base of subscribers
which
represents their entire source of income
i think that's unrealistic for most
people
and i don't think that advertising as a
revenue source is going to go away
i think successful passion economy
entrepreneurs
they are cobbling together different
sources of income
through different mechanisms one of
which might be subscriptions
and payments from one's audience but
there's a lot of other pieces of the pie
um there's a youtube video that i
recently watched
from this youtuber called linus tech
tips he's like a
pretty popular youtuber i think he has
something like 20 million followers
um and he showed his revenue breakdown
in a in a pie chart and
like what really struck me was that
advertising based revenue whether it was
sponsored videos or affiliate links
amazon affiliate program adsense they
actually
made up the majority of his earnings out
of the entire year
um like it was it was um
by far the majority of his earnings and
then a smaller
sliver of his total earnings as a
company came from
fan subscriptions and i think he used um
or direct fan payments and those fan
payments were comprised of
merchandise that he sold through an
online e-commerce store
as well as he had this platform that he
used
to distribute premium content
to people who would pay for it so
premium videos or early access videos
before he posted them on youtube
and i thought that was really
interesting because i think for
for everyone who's trying to
create a living for themselves like it's
you can actually reach a far greater
base
of potential customers and fans if you
don't ask everyone to pay like
the subscription model is inherently
exclusive
um it supposes that your audience has
disposable income to pay for whatever
you're creating
um and a lot of people don't have that
and i think
advertising is actually quite
democratizing because
everyone can have access to what you're
creating and not have to buy anything
um and not have to pay out of pocket
yeah
what's really interesting about this is
um kind of
your understanding um and i think kind
of the
perspective of there's no one
strategy that everyone can take right
and so that's not only
industry wise right saying hey if you
want to go be
a writer on the internet there's not
even a one size fits all for writers on
the internet right it's actually
each individual person has a different
path to pursue
um and it feels like some of that is
audience driven so who is your audience
or who do you want your audience to be
but also too it sounds almost like it
may be personal preference driven as
well right
meaning that i don't want to go sell ads
therefore i have to find a different
uh methodology or somebody who says i
don't want to ask my audience to
pay for this i would rather have ads
supported
is that kind of a fair way to look at
the
almost decision tree that some of these
uh folks are going through
yeah exactly i i very much agree with
that and i think you can decompose
personal preference into a lot of sub
components too
i think it's like where you are in the
creator
life cycle like are you still trying to
build up an audience space
or have you reached the stage where you
you think your audience is big enough
and you want to start monetizing them i
think another one is like
how attractive is your demographic to
advertisers like if you were to try and
do advertising
how successful would you be and what
would be the rates that you would be
able to charge
and then i think a third component is
like um
what do you enjoy doing and how much
effort do you want to put in
because i think creating subscription
content oftentimes is
a lot more work and a heavier lift than
just selling ads
with advertising you can get you know a
big sponsor
and they just pay you a lump sum amount
and that takes care of the bills for the
next few months
with a subscription offering you have to
consistently be creating output
like i've i've heard from people um who
have
a patreon page set up that they feel
like they have to create
they have to offer these member benefits
basically into perpetuity they can't
stop
because then you'll lose your
subscribers and you're sort of breaking
their trust
that's not the case with advertising and
so i i completely agree that there's no
one-size-fits-all
path and it's really a function of
personal preference
where you are in your life cycle
the degree to which you want to
like how much effort and work you want
to put in
yeah talk to me a little bit about uh
building brands and digital communities
so
obviously i think a lot of people think
of the output right so if you're a
writer i write words and then i put that
out there
but it doesn't kind of absolve people
from thinking
through maybe one uh this idea of
intellectual property
around a brand and kind of really
getting people to buy into and align
values with and want to continue to
consume content from that brand
but also too this idea of uh you can
have kind of subscribers so people who
just pay you
you could have members of a community
like there's almost this
uh varying degree of your relationship
with the
people that you are um you know
interacting with creating for
serving with a service or whatever how
do you think about building brands and
digital communities
hmm this is an interesting question
first of all i would say i'm not the
expert on this topic
i think i've kind of accidentally built
a personal brand
and stumbled into building an online
community
um why do you say accidentally
because the goal of
my content creation my blogging
activities
has always been how do i just provide
value to founders
how do i package up my ideas
in a way that i think would be helpful
and valuable to them it was never about
me
it was about them and serving them um
like i've mentioned this in conversation
with paulina before but my bar of
publishing something is super high
if i don't feel like this is going to
um be extremely additive
to someone's life and the company that
they're building
and i i can't justify taking the time
away from their day
to stop working on everything else that
is a priority to just read my writing
if i don't think a piece of work reaches
that level i don't publish it
and so i have a huge uh google
drive folder full of all these blog
posts that i've written that i just
don't think
are that helpful to founders and so i i
didn't publish them just for the sake of
publishing
um like i i everything that i do
is through the lens of like do i think
this really helps a ton of people
and that's why i say the brand building
has been accidental
um i think through that people feel like
my writing
is very unique and authentic in the
entire landscape of
venture industry writing um but yeah for
me it was never about
personal brand building yeah and and
then what about this idea of like
digital communities right so
you know take sub stack as an example
you can be a sub stack writer and you
can simply publish an email every day
and you basically have readers and
readers to me
sets this expectation that i'm going to
write the readers are going to read
maybe one percent of them respond and
there's some engagement but for the most
part it's a one-way communication
um and they're basically paying me for
those thoughts or words
uh if you then instead say but i want to
build a
community that implies something
different right that's a different
expectation it's almost now saying no
the
readers are going to communicate with
each other and with me and it's more of
an
ongoing like larger value proposition to
some degree
is that kind of how you see it or or do
you think of communities as
kind of something else or use a
different framework maybe to look
through that
yeah well so first of all i think the
term community is like wildly
overview overused in the
tech industry right now because everyone
wants to have other people believe that
there's network effects to their
business and so everyone
claims to have a vibrant engaged
community even if what they really have
is just
a list of instagram followers and so to
level set on like what i
believe a community is and how i define
it is i think it's a group of people who
have really strong bonds with each other
not just with the creator who is leading
the community but with each other
there's a network
like a mesh network of very strong
pairwise bonds
and people um have
mutual concern and interest for each
other
um so that's how i define it and so i
think
when we're talking about substituters or
other content creators who are now
cultivating communities and creating
digital spaces
for their audience to um gather in one
place and
discuss whatever shared interests or
topics or
um content that they all find
interesting
um i think about it from that angle of
like what
is the actual um like what is the need
that the community is serving
what ties everyone together um how
do people relate to each other in that
community um
what is the source of their bond and i
think as a
community leader admin creator
like you have to start from first
principles and start
with asking yourself that question of
like what is the value that people are
trying to seek from this
place how are they relating to each
other how can people
benefit from each other and how can you
deepen the care that everyone feels for
each other
versus just aggregating your followers
into one place so that they consume more
of your content like i think
the latter is actually what a lot of
people are trying to do
but it's like a faux community
absolutely
before we get into the rapid fire
questions to end i want to talk a little
bit about this idea you have around the
passion economy
being a catalyst to help rebuild middle
america
or middle class if you will it's not
necessarily the geography middle america
but the middle class
can you elaborate on that idea a little
bit and help people understand what you
mean by that
yeah totally um so this ties a little
bit back to the conversation that we had
earlier around the passion economy
versus the creator economy
um so just personally and as an investor
i'm not just interested in how do we
enable the next wave of celebrities to
be built
online and how do we help the
top one percent of content creators make
a ton of money
um i'm i mean i think that's cool and
all and that's great for them
but i am actually much more interested
in the long tail
of how do we empower anyone in the
country
to be able to make an income doing what
they love
and that necessitates empowering the
long tail and
helping people who don't
have a huge base of followers or fans to
be able to
earn money from what they love to do
and so i think tying this to the middle
class thing
um i mean everyone has probably seen the
stats
online uh around how the middle class in
america has shrunk
substantially in the past few decades i
think it's dropped by about 10
percentage points since
1970 and um in addition to that
income disparity is widening in america
between the upper class and the middle
class
um and i think obviously the
solutions well first the reasons for why
this is the case it's
it's very multifaceted and complex and
therefore
the solutions um to combat this are also
very complex and nuanced and i don't
think that
technology is going to solve everything
i think that it requires
a multi-disciplinary approach involving
policy shifts in societal attitudes but
i think
technology can play its part as well i
would
i consider myself to be a huge techno
optimist like i believe that technology
does have the potential to really
improve
people's lives and to make the world a
better place
and specifically the version of that
that
i want to push forward is a world in
which people are building technology
that helps to broaden
access to income and to customers and to
give people new ways of working
that feel more meaningful and fulfilling
to them i think technology can create
new jobs i think
technology can broaden access to new
types of careers that were previously
really inaccessible
to lots of people like i think if you
had asked people 10 years ago do they
think they can make a living full-time
as a newsletter writer just writing a
newsletter once a week i think most
people would have said no
and i think that answer has meaningfully
shifted in the last couple of years
because of technology so i'm really
excited
around new platforms that are giving
people
new ways of working new tools to help
them build an income
and specifically doing that in a way
that can empower
not just a handful of people to be
really successful but
tens if not hundreds of millions of
people around the world
yeah uh i tend to one agree and two i
think that that is uh
the best possible path forward right is
uh is one where the world continues to
improve
uh and technology plays a big part of it
so uh not only do i agree but i'm uh i'm
hoping that that is the case as well
um yeah well we can do our part as
investors
to help support those companies
absolutely i always ask the same two
questions to uh to wrap up and then you
get to ask me one to uh to end it but
the first one is just what is the most
important book that you have ever read
wow oh my gosh there's so many
um it's hard to narrow it down but
i i talk about this book all the time
um it's jane eyre by charlotte bronte
i i guess this is probably
unconventional to mention on your
podcast but it's a
romance novel um why do you like that
one
i read it when i was 13 years old and
just
immediately felt like
it felt like my eyes were open to
a brand new color that had previously
not been visible to me
yeah it just describes love
and emotions in such a beautiful
way like the passages between jane and
rochester
in that novel are i think some of the
most beautiful
sentences that have ever been written in
the english language
and i yeah i just have a
keen appreciation for beauty um
and i appreciate
love i think it's why we're put on this
earth i think
we exist for love um and i think that
novel
encapsulates a lot of that yeah and how
much of it do you think was just
uh the period in time when you read it
right kind of at 13 years old
um if you'd read it at a different you
know point your life do you think it
would have had the same impact
or maybe it hadn't had more more or less
impact
like if i had read it as a jaded adult
um i think it helps me from from
i i think it reading it when i did has
helped me
resist becoming jaded as an adult
that's a great answer uh second question
is uh much more fun
which is aliens are you a believer or
non-believer absolutely
oh yes absolutely without hesitation i
mean just mathematically
it's like it's impossible right for us
to be the only
beings in the entire universe if it's
really infinite and vast like i
i just don't think that we can possibly
be that special
and i think mathematically we are also
probably living in a simulation
i i tend to believe that much more than
i think other people do
and uh i always try to understand it's
cheating because i feel like
when you're in the tech world that's
probably a very high rate of belief
on the simulation versus like the
average
uh citizen but um
it's a non-zero chance we can put it at
that right
yeah like if you read through that essay
arguing for why we are living in a
simulation it just makes logical sense
i know that a lot of people disagree
with me and so i hope i don't i haven't
just completely undermined
the rest of this podcast with that you
would be surprised i think there's a lot
of people who
listen to this who actually agree you
could ask me uh one question to finish
up what's the one question you have for
me
hmm if you were making a homemade
pizza what toppings would you put on it
so i cheat i wouldn't make a homemade
pizza
everyone knows that i ordered dominoes
every saturday
uh and uh i only get pepperoni pizza
and uh i get cheesy bread uh
as like the side and for me it's all
about like the consistency
of like when you order you know what
you're gonna get right um
you're loyal to the same pizza yeah i
have one friend
uh who i'm not gonna say cause i don't
know if he wants this known or not but
uh he's somebody in the technology world
that
you probably know uh and he makes
homemade pizzas all the time
and uh every time he posts a picture of
it
it always has like different toppings
and different things and i think that
if i had to guess like there's this
enjoyment of like experimentation
and uh trying to get better
and improve at like making the pizza and
so i think that people who make
pizza at home they don't just go with
like oh i always make pepperoni pizza
like part of the joy of doing it is
we're gonna try different things i'm
gonna you know use different sauces i'm
gonna
use different toppings i'm gonna use
different type of bread or whatever um
and uh that's not me in terms of going
to do that but like
it would almost be like what are the
ones that you would try
more so than like you would use every
single time right because
right the whole idea of like being the
homemade pizza maker
it's kind of like bread like i don't
know anyone who makes the same bread
every single you know night it's usually
they kind of experiment with different
things try different ones and
part of the experience is oh this one
was good or like
you know what lee like you messed this
one up right
so yeah you're just going for like
guaranteed something that you know you
already like
and just consistency i
continue to say because everyone
obviously doesn't like the fact that i
like dominoes
i like domino's i think it's the best
like take out pizza
by far by far now i live in new york
city which is
you know that's what gets everyone riled
up is because there's okay i forgot
and so i always say that like yes there
is better pizza than dominoes in new
york
but uh there's also a lot of pizza
that's way worse
than domino's as well and so if you want
to play kind of russian roulette
in order from places you don't know sure
knock yourself out um
i have a couple of favorites like joe's
pizza etc that i will get
but uh if i just i want to know what i'm
ordering right now
domino's is uh domino's pepperoni got it
so all right lee thank you so much for
doing this i really appreciate it where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or kind of consume some of the
content you've been putting out
yeah so i publish a newsletter it's on
substack it's lead.substack.com
i have a two letter sub domain which
they no longer give out so it's very og
um so yeah lead.substack.com or um
if you know anyone has an interesting
startup that they're working on that
relates to any of the themes that we
talked about
they can reach me at my email
atelierventures.com
awesome all right well thank you so much
for doing this we will definitely do
this again in the future
and uh and best of luck as you uh as you
kind of start investing on
on these new themes thank you so much
this was really fun i
i enjoyed it a ton